[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
and i'm so happy that lamplighter is
finally getting some much-needed
character development
after he was skipped over in the comics
thank
god lamplighter
how we barely knew thee however we
pieced together everything that we could
collect on the character
and throughout this video we're going to
be going through the ins and outs of his
backstory
powers and more there will be some
spoilers here so if you haven't seen up
to episode 7 of season 2
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
and smash that thumbs up button if you
love the boys
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into lamplighter
okay so when we first come across
lamplighter in the comics
the character is crawling around in his
own feces
mumbling about his fire before we ever
met him
lamplighter had been killed by colonel
mallory and thus
he was in a zombie-like state though we
haven't witnessed it in the show so far
in the source material compound v has
several negative properties to it
including an almost resurrection-like
quality that fires up the neurons in
one's brain
at the instant of death this means that
though the soups are technically dead
they're reanimated and are capable of
moving around and talking
however one shouldn't view it so much as
them having a life
and due to their lack of brain cells
caused by their death
they're very much brain dead that's why
when you look up quotes from the guy
most of them are just stuff like well
what am i
where am i from sounds like some of the
comments i get haha
got you suckers
now this resurrection process very much
allows a vote to make it seem like their
heroes are invincible
and even in the face of death that
they'll always come back
we've seen things like this carried out
in comic books like the death of
superman
and batman nightfall in which the
characters were seemingly defeated
but they came back even stronger yes i
know batman didn't die in nightfall
so you can stop typing right now now
vault follow a similar sort of procedure
and they come up with elaborate
backstories on how the characters died
and then were able to return however
it's all just a pr stunt
and after the heroes are paraded around
for a couple of months
they are quote unquote retired by the
company and cast to the side
now what we do know about lamplighter is
that like the rest of the seven
his mother was given extreme amounts of
compound v
during her pregnancy this procedure was
finessed during the second world war
when vault worked with the nazis
alongside vogelbaum
to find a way to make the aryan superman
a reality
vor of course fled to america taking his
procedures with him
and as we say the rest is history now in
the source material we learn
very little about lamplighter and
predominantly his story is told in
flashbacks
lamplighter was actually the member of
the seven just before starlight
and she was brought in to replace him it
was primarily during 911 that his
downfall first started
and if you don't know in the comics
during the historical event
the seven were brought in to stop a
plane from crashing into the towers
this was supposed to be a big pr stunt
for the group
in which they would miraculously save
the day however
in the end things went disastrously
similar to the plane rescue seen in the
show
homeland ended up causing a lot of
damage to it
and it crashed into the brooklyn bridge
killing thousands
the terrorists were blamed but the cia
knew the truth
and thus they started to close in on the
group volt wanted nothing more than to
have the seven working alongside the
military
as it would massively raise their
profile but the cia attempted to
blackmail vote in order to stop this
from becoming a reality
this motif was of course adapted in the
recent boys season
and similar to how it played out on
screen lamplighter refused to be
blackmailed
he stalked colonel mallory and then
killed his grandchildren
when he was out of his home the show
actually follows a similar pattern to
this
but where it differs is that lamplighter
didn't intentionally do it
and he has remorse over the killings
because of this
in the series he stepped out of the
limelight and he ended up working at the
sage grove center for stormfront
in the source material after the death
of his grandchildren mallory is of
course devastated
and he realizes that things have gone
too far and will continue to escalate
thus a ceasefire is called between the
seven and the cia
and together the groups meet in an air
force hangar
the boys arrive to find the hangar
completely red from top to bottom
and we learned that it's been painted
with the blood of an army platoon
in order to intimidate them into
agreeing to the terms of the deal
both the seven and the boys want a
ceasefire brought about
and to show their good will towards the
situation the seven
actually hand over lamplia to mallory
mallory ends up beating the crap out of
the character
before shooting him and then throwing
him out of an airplane
bought then takes his body and after v
resurrects him
they parade him around for a while
before locking him in a dungeon
starlight then replaces him in the group
and as punishment she's forced to clean
his cell
which we find him climbing around in
covered in crap
yikes now where the show differs from
this is that lamplighter just goes to
the sage grove
center and is used by stormfront to burn
the evidence of her experiments with
compound b
when the boys arrive one day and he and
frenchie come face to face
he begins to atone for what he did to
mallory's grandchildren
and decides to join them in their quest
to take down bought
in episode 7 we learn that he's planning
to testify against the corporation
however because of the actions he takes
he never gets to the courtroom
we discover that in the show's universe
lamplighter was pretty much
forced into being a suit by his father
who wanted the fame and fortune that
came with this
lamplighter even remarks that his dad
was happy when he burned down their home
and it clearly shows what kind of plans
he had for him
lamplighter filled the role brilliantly
but as we mentioned
he just couldn't take the fact that the
cia had dirt on him
his father's view of him being a hero is
what likely made him think that he
should try and cover it up at all costs
and this was of course a grave mistake
for him
in the end lamplighter just wanted to be
a hero but he ruined his chances
as did most of the seven it's okay
starlight
i still love you he set himself on fire
in front of the statue of the seven
which was a reference to the burning
monk which in some ways was a protest
for everything that they stood for
i actually think that the character
might even come back at some point
and i would love to see the resurrection
qualities of v in the comics brought
across the show
lamplighter's body is of course still in
bought tower
i think it would be amazing to go
seasons down the line
and have the boys break in there only to
find him crawling around
like how he does in the comics that's
pretty much all you need to know about
his history and comic book origin
and as for his powers they're a lot more
straightforward
now like all those injected with v
lamblier has enhanced abilities such as
increased strength and durability
this means he can withstand much more
damage than a regular person
but he's nowhere near as invincible as
homelander or stonefront
who can have her bloody tats burned and
be fine burn her bloody tats
now his main ability is pyrokinesis
which allows him to control and
manipulate fire
lamplighter can take tiny flames and
turn them into engulfing blasts
but he has to have a source for this in
order to yield it this is why he carries
around his gigantic staff
and within this is an almost ever
burning flame that he can pull from
now lamb light air is actually riffing
on a number of comic book characters
including green lantern and thor the
former
is because he well he uses a lantern and
and dresses in green
and the second is because his weapon is
very much part of his getup
with thor it is of course which i always
pronounce wrong
and with lamb lighter it's it's
obviously it
it's his lamplighter now i was really
shocked that he went out the way that he
did
and i hope that we do get him back in
some form or another
i absolutely love sean ashmore and
seeing him playing pretty much an
opposite to iceman from the x-men was a
brilliant move by the creative team
to parody the superhero genre even more
anyway that's everything that you need
to know about the character
but if there's anything that you'd like
to add then make sure you comment below
and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up make sure you check out
our breakdown of stormfront which is
going to be linked at the end
we go over everything you need to know
about the character including her
origins powers and more
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want something else to watch
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat just on a discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you